ARUN NAGARAJAN:
Hello and welcome
to Google Developers Live.
My name is Arun
Nagarajan and I'm
with the Google Apps
Developer Relations team.
Today we have a very
special guest on the show.
We have a great partner,
Avery, and they're
going to be talking about the
great Google Docs and Google
Sheets add-ons that
they've been working on.
And before we dive
into all the demos
and interesting
conversation, I want
to have Brad introduce himself.
BRAD NELSON: Hello.
My name is Brad Nelson from
Avery Products Corporation.
I'm very glad to be here
with Arun, seeing you again
after Google I/O.
The business I'm in is
being able to have people
buy our various
products from Staples,
or whatever distributor
might have it.
Take the stock home and
load it in your printer.
Use one of our applications
to design a customized label
or card.
Perhaps a business card
or a greeting card.
And then you print it right
on your own printer at home.
We have materials suited
for inkjet and for lasers.
So we got you covered
as the consumer.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
Why don't we actually do a
very quick demo of the product?
The add-on.
BRAD NELSON: I'd
be glad to do that.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: All right.
Let's take a quick look.
BRAD NELSON: So this was
developed with a Google Apps
Script.
And we've been working on it
on and off for a few months.
I wouldn't say we've been
spending full time on it.
But it's been really easy to do.
I really like the technology.
My background is quite a bit
of client-server, Java, Flash,
HTML.
And so I'm very
familiar with the model.
And it was quite simple and
easy to put this application
together.
So let's dive into it.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Let's do it.
BRAD NELSON: So this is called
Avery Design and Print app
for Google Drive.
And on our first screen--
this is a web-based release.
We could either pick between
a Google Spreadsheet or Google
Contacts.
So let's say that
I pick Spreadsheet
and then I hit the Next button.
Very simple interface.
It shows a list of
all the spreadsheets
that I have in my
own Google Drive.
And so I'll just
pick one of these.
Call it Address List.
I have to press a button here so
that I can run Apps Script that
will actually parse
that spreadsheet
and convert it
into a CSB stream.
And once I've done that,
there'll be a little spinner.
It finishes and if I
hit the Merge button,
I'll actually be
taking that data
into our website for a merge.
But what I'd rather do is show
that second step with Contacts.
So we'll just back up here.
And we'll do the same process.
We'll start with Contacts
instead of Spreadsheets.
Go to Next.
And I have the option of picking
either home or work addresses.
Because we're going to make
mailing labels from Contacts.
And I can actually,
after picking one,
say well what if there
isn't a home address.
There's only a work address.
So we have this little check box
there that says use either one.
So it'll prefer home.
If it's not there it'll
look for a work address.
Again, I have to go grab
the Contacts and format
that into a CSB format,
and now I'm ready to merge.
At this point we're going to
enter the Design and Print
Online application.
And while that loads,
we have a large range
of products on the left
side of the screen here,
business cards, labels.
I'm going to go with a label.
The 5160 is very
common mailing label.
I'm just going to show
a series of designs.
These are called
pre-design templates.
So we'll just pick
any one of those.
And after it loads
the template, you
see that merged data that's
come out of Contacts.
So we show a
spreadsheet format here.
And if you want to not include
all the rows of contacts,
you can simply disable the
ones you don't want to merge.
And then you can go on.
At this step, we are allowing
you to do a drag and drop
interface so that
you can specify where
you want the fields from
that contact list to show up.
And typically, it would
just be Name, Address.
And I can drag over Country.
And so these fields
are filled in.
And the merge will be completed.
And now we'll go to
the design canvas
and you can see the actual data.
So this is one of the
contacts in my contact list.
Here's a few more.
So each one of these
labels here has
been merged from
Google Contacts.
So that's really
nice Apps Script.
And to complete
the demo, we would
go into Preview and Printing.
So you could see what
the sheet of Avery labels
would look like.
This is a shipping label format.
But this is a 30 up-- we
call it-- mailing label.
And I'm going to
go ahead and show
that we create a PDF
file, which we can open.
And at this point
we can print it.
ARUN NAGARAJAN:
Well thank you very
much for sharing that with us.
And giving your
insights on Apps Script.
And I hope you found
that really useful.
And more importantly, I hope
you go check out the add-on
and install it and try it out.
I think it's going
to be really useful.
Especially around the holidays.
Especially around
other times when
you need to send out a lot
of either greeting cards
or mailing labels.
I know I've used the products.
BRAD NELSON: That's great.
Well we're looking forward to
doing an add-in on your store
next.
An app for the store
that you suggested
to us for spreadsheets.
So that will be
our next evolution.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Great.
Thank you very much.